Turquía vota mañana en la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales un
hecho inédito que los turcos y turcas
harán por primera vez en su historia hoy
por lo tanto finalizan los actos de
campaña de ambos candidatos con una
oposición que sabe que va por detrás en
los sondeos y un resetta hiperdogan
totalmente crecido sobre todo en esta
última semana lo recordemos que la
primera vuelta
consiguió el
49,5% de los votos y también aseguró una
mayoría parlamentaria con más de 300
escaños Por su parte el líder opositor
que licharo Lulu se quedó con el
44,9% del apoyo esta última semana ha
sido totalmente marcada para ver cómo se
repartían los votos ultranacionalistas
que recordemos en la primera vuelta
sacaron un 5% del apoyo por parte de su
principal candidato sin anuar quien esta
misma semana ha dado todo su apoyo a
recepta hii erdogan es por lo tanto este
5% de los del apoyo una un gran número
para que erdogan pueda revalidar su
presidencia este mismo domingo